y
al menos tres mil migrantes partieron en
una nueva caravana desde tapachula en el
sur de méxico hacia el norte del país
este es el más reciente intento para
llegar a pie a eeuu en agosto la guardia
nacional disolvió otra marcha tendremos
invitados
el presidente de turquía recep tayib
erdogán ordenó al ministerio de
exteriores que declarar 'persona no
grata' a 10 embajadores la molestia del
gobierno es que ellos firmaron un
manifiesto para pedir la liberación del
activista osman cábala que lleva cuatro
años en prisión domiciliaria y el ex
ministro del interior de italia matteo
salvini enfrentó su primer día de juicio
el líder del partido ultraderechista la
liga es acusado de secuestro porque
impidió que embargo con más de 140
migrantes que se marcara en su país en
la bio era de la ong open arts
conversamos con ellas
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
informativa de france 24 yo soy madre
clara calle y es un gusto estar con
ustedes comenzamos en américa latina'
porque la denominada caravana madre
salió desde la ciudad de tapachula en
mexico hacia la capital del país al
menos 3000 migrantes intentan llegar al
norte mexicano y cruzar hacia eeuu ellos
protestan por la demora en sus procesos
de asilo mientras están hacinados en
campamentos en el sur del país la
mayoría vienen de haití y también hay
personas de suramérica y américa central
y
ya no podemos más acá no tenemos trabajo
no podemos vivir en nuestro país mucho
peor no hay trámites están muy difíciles
todo todo sale con mentiras no tienen
palabra llegar hasta la frontera si dios
lo permite y cumplir cada uno de
nuestras metas nosotros tenemos una
familia y tenemos muy buenos
ustedes escuchaban a algunos de los
migrantes que hacen parte de esta nueva
caravana antes de hoy en tapachula se
tomaron varios días para organizar la
cruzada y es que a esta ciudad mexicana
y fronteriza con guatemala ha llegado
una cantidad inusual de migrantes para
entender qué está pasando está con
nosotros desde ciudad de méxico jorge
andrade él es doctor en antropología y
especialista en temas migratorios señor
andrade gracias por estar con nosotros
en france 24 que están pidiendo los
migrantes que hacen parte de esta
caravana
pues es una caravana más que están
organizando con la idea que quieren
llegar a eeuu lo cual no va a ser
así
[Música]
qué avance o cree entonces
no solamente en galaxias sino que llega
en eeuu
es complicado las fronteras están
cerradas
no nada más físicamente sino activamente
no hay
una situación complicada para estas
personas
y usted nos hablaba de la dificultad de
llegar a estados unidos pero en
tapachula la ciudad mexicana que está
pasando en materia de migración y por
qué importa esta ciudad
bueno
históricamente es una de las fronteras
más porosas
el país
históricamente lo comentaba es por donde
llegan los grupos no solamente
centroamericanos sudamericanos
caribeños
transcontinentales entonces la entidad
hacia méxico para tomar un camino sin
dos unidos y posible maxilar es en donde
necesitan
[Música]
pues la detención de todas estas
personas que están esperando un trámite
de hamburgo
en los últimos días se ha registrado que
han llegado migrantes de por lo menos 11
países a esta ciudad que usted describe
pero explíquenos un poco porque ha
aumentado la migración últimamente tanto
en centroamérica como en el norte del
continente
económica
y que conlleva hacia otras situaciones
como la miseria la pobreza
las catástrofes climáticas carnés
terremotos y la falsa idea que se manejó
de que con la administración de pago iba
a cambiar
está
situación de los migrantes que iban a
ser recibidos pero se les aglutinando
la administración de obama se
devolvieron por lo menos en el caso
mexicano más de 2 millones de personas
hacia nuestro país el que era el que se
estaba encargando de esa política para
trabajar en el mirador es un crecimiento
entonces esa idea falsa
señor andrade muchas gracias por las
explicaciones que nos dan y nosotros
cambiamos a una noticia de última hora
porque el hombre más buscado por las
autoridades de colombia fue capturado
fuentes del ejército y la policía le
confirmaron a medios locales que
atraparon a dairo antonio úsuga alias
otoniel él es el jefe del clan del golfo
y buscado por narcotráfico colombia
había ofrecido una recompensa de 800 mil
dólares y eeuu ofreció cinco millones de
dólares por información que permitiera
su captura en este momento el presidente
iván duque y la cúpula militar están
viajando hacia el norte del país donde
ocurrió la captura seguiremos informando
sobre esta noticia del desarrollo
y pasamos a haití porque se cumple una
semana desde el secuestro de 17
misioneros norteamericanos en haití el
gobierno haitiano trabaja en conjunto
con oficiales estadounidenses en el caso
pero todavía no hay reportes oficiales
sobre dónde están los secuestrados no
obstante fuentes del ejecutivo han
confirmado que los misioneros fueron
retenidos por la banda 400 magos o que
pide un rescate de 17 millones de
dólares un millón por cada retenido
veamos más en este informe una semana
después del secuestro de este orfanato
en haití 17 miembros de un grupo
misionero norteamericano podrían
permanecer en cualquier parte de la isla
el pasado sábado 16 estadounidenses un
canadiense y su conductor haitiano
fueron secuestrados en el grupo hay
cinco niños incluyendo uno de ocho meses
estaban en ahí tiene una misión con los
ministerios de ayuda cristiana con sede
en ohio desde sus ciudades de origen las
familias se enviaron una carta
agradeciendo a la gente alrededor del
mundo por sus oraciones
siguen uniéndose y apoyándose con
oraciones y ánimo en estos momentos
difíciles es increíble como los tiempos
difíciles tienen una de unir a la gente
oremos por estas familias se encuentran
en una situación difícil
la declaración de la familia llega días
después de que se publicara un vídeo en
el que se ve al líder de la banda 400
mabus diciendo que matara a los rehenes
si no cumplen sus exigencias la banda
pide un millón de dólares por cada red
la secretaria de prensa a los eeuu dijo
que el fbi está trabajando con las
autoridades haitianas
obviamente estamos trabajando sin
descanso para atraer a estas personas a
casa son ciudadanos estadounidenses y en
el transcurso de los últimos años se ha
atacado norteamericanos en haití tan
sólo este año se ha producido al menos
455 secuestros que son habituales en
haití donde la anarquía y la violencia
de las bandas está en aumento el jueves
cientos de haitianos cerraron un barrio
un puerto príncipe en protestas contra
el gobierno en la creciente inseguridad
de haití las bandas bloquean la
distribución de gasolina y los
secuestros y uno de los mejores
deportistas de ecuador fue asesinado en
la ciudad de guayaquil se trata de la
atleta alex quiñones finalista de los
200 metros de los juegos olímpicos de
londres-2012 las autoridades todavía no
saben cuáles son las causas del
homicidio que ocurrió anoche su
asesinato se produjo en el cuarto día
del estado de excepción que declaró el
presidente del país guillermo lasso
precisamente por el aumento de los
homicidios
y decenas de partidarios del fundador de
wikileaks julian assange protestaron en
el centro de londres pidiendo que no lo
extraditen esta manifestación se produce
antes de la audiencia de apelación que
se realizará esta semana en la que eeuu
pedirá de nuevo su extradición todo por
los cargos de espionaje que está
enfrentando la justicia británica ya
había bloqueado el proceso assange se
encuentra en una prisión londinense
desde 2019
y el presidente de turquía recep tayyip
erdogán le ordenó al ministerio de
exteriores que declarar 'persona no
grata' a 10 embajadores entre ellos
están los de eeuu alemania y francia el
descontento de mandatario es porque
ellos firmaron un manifiesto para pedir
la liberación del empresario y activista
osman cabal a quien lleva cuatro años en
prisión preventiva tras haber sido
acusado de instigar las protestas de
2013 la declaración del presidente
significa que el país de procedencia de
los embajadores tiene un periodo
determinado para retirarlos de lo
contrario turquía puede expulsarlos de
su territorio
no puedes atreverte a venir al
ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
turquía y dar órdenes aquí
y la orden necesaria nuestro ministro de
relaciones exteriores y le dije lo que
se debe hacer estos diez embajadores
deben ser declarados personas non grata
y lo resolverá de inmediato
hablemos de italia porque en la ciudad
de palermo terminó el primer día del
juicio contra el ex ministro del
interior- matteo salvini el
ultraderechista es acusado de secuestro
por haber negado que un barco con más de
140 migrantes desembarcará el navío de
la ong open arms esperó en el mar
durante 19 días al salir de la audiencia
hoy el exfuncionario descalificó a las
ong diciendo que actúan por intereses
económicos jorge hurtado tiene la
historia
el juicio inició el ex ministro de
interior italiano matteo salvini tuvo su
primer cara a cara con la justicia que
lo acusa de secuestro tras su decisión
en 2019 que un barco con más de 100
migrantes a bordo no desembarcará en su
país al salir de la audiencia salvini
recordó que 12 países de la unión
europea pidieron crear muros para
controlar la migración y criticó el
proceso en su contra andará proceso a
europa con miedo verdad es su redada es
surrealista someterse a juicio porque he
hecho mi trabajo me da pena porque digo
que ser yo puede ser un juicio en el que
richard gere viene de hollywood a dar
testimonio de mi carrera espero que dure
lo menos posible porque hay cosas más
importantes que hacer lo que dure menos
posibles
importantes los migrantes quedaron
varados en el mar durante casi tres
semanas a bordo del barco de rescate de
la ong open arms hasta que los fiscales
ordenaron la incautación del barco y la
evacuación de todos los que estaban a
bordo pero para salvini él solo hizo
cumplir la ley cuesta una nave pirata
se trata de un barco pirata que recogió
inmigrantes en aguas libias el primero
de agosto de 2019 y recogió inmigrantes
en aguas maltesas el 2 de agosto
el maltés bordo dicha es un barco que
tiene derecho a llevar 19 inmigrantes a
bordo y al final tenía más de 150 de
ellos si alguien ha cometido un delito y
ha puesto en riesgo la vida de las
personas es el comandante de este barco
pirata y no ministro que defendía a su
país ministro gadifer eso para eso serán
más de 50 los testigos de este proceso
entre ellos ex ministros de interior de
italia el juicio continuará el 17 de
diciembre y de ser declarado culpable
por la justicia siciliana salvini podría
enfrentar hasta 15 años de cárcel
como lo veíamos en la nota del caso
contra el exministro matteo salvini es
por un barco de open arms esta es una
ong española que ha rescatado a cientos
de migrantes en el mar mediterráneo
según ellos en este mar han muerto más
de 20.000 personas y por eso lo
califican como la mayor fosa común del
planeta previamente hablamos con oscar
camps fundador de open arms él respondió
a las acusaciones que hizo el ex
funcionario italiano y que acusó a las
ong de actuar por intereses económicos y
no por humanidad
bueno nosotros somos una organización
humanitaria que nos dedicamos a proteger
la vida en el mar sobre todo en aguas
internacionales
no tenemos intercambios económicos ni si
no tenemos a ninguna
ninguna otra por radio ni civil ni
militar
como es el caso de la misma técnica
liana no él siempre nos acusa nos estaba
acusando siempre y esta es su tónica y
su estrategia no no obstante desde que
está sentado en el banquillo de los
acusados y no nosotros
en otras noticias de europa el
presidente del gobierno de españa pedro
sánchez indicó que buscará acelerar la
entrega de ayudas a las industrias
agrícolas y pesqueras más afectadas en
la isla de la palma y es que la lava del
volcán cumbre vieja continúa fluyendo
más de un mes después de que comenzaron
las erupciones ya van 900 hectáreas de
tierra que se han visto cubiertas al
tiempo que más de 2.000 edificios han
sido destruidos a principios de octubre
sánchez anunció 206 millones de euros
para reconstruir la infraestructura
afectada y ayudar a las industrias de la
isla en el consejo de ministros de este
próximo martes vamos a hacer una
modificación presupuestaria al fondo de
contingencias para que se acelere aún
más rápido la llegada de los recursos
económicos provenientes tanto del plan
de empleo 63 millones de euros que
estaban inscritos en el plan de
reconstrucción a la palma como las
ayudas del ministerio de agricultura y
pesca que son 6 millones 800 mil euros
para todo el sector de agricultura y de
pesca tan importante en la isla de la
palma ya propósito de volcanes
terminamos con uno de los más activos
del mundo el llamado etna entró en una
nueva erupción y ya está expulsando humo
y cenizas como ven en las imágenes este
volcán está ubicado en sicilia la isla
italiana sólo este año ha entrado en
erupción más de 50 veces sin embargo
generalmente no provoca daños ni pone en
riesgo a la población que vive cerca al
volcán con más de 3 mil 300 metros es el
volcán más alto y más activo que tiene
todo el viejo continente
y con estas imágenes nos despedimos por
ahora pero sigan conectados con france24
y esperen a mi compañero andrés meza en
las noticias